can amd's new laptop processors really  beat out apple's m2 chip in the macbook  air well this 6800 hs uses 65 watts of  power compared to 20 and has 16 threads  which result in about 50 percent more  raw performance in cinebench but what  about real world use well as far as web  browsing the macbook is way faster and  when we get into tougher tasks for  example 4k video editing it also beats  it out without any issues now that does  use some encoders but lightroom doesn't  and the macbook is still  faster and if you use final cut with  prores the difference is insane the only  time this lenovo won was in blender  because of the nvidia graphics but in  most real world tasks the macbook smoked  it which is why you can't just go off of  raw specs